- Can I get a real quick
weird selfie with you?
- Yes, you can!
- Oh, I got it.
(upbeat music)
Okay.
One. Two. Three.
Awesome.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah!
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
You're feeling the pressure.
- All right. All right.
- [Man] We've got to hold
on on what we've got.
- Oh, uh. Uh.
(buzzer)
♪ Na nana nana nana make it or not ♪
♪ Ooh we're halfway there. ♪
"Living On A Prayer." Bon Jovi.
(ding)
(cheering)
- [Man] It's a dance off,
ladies and gentlemen.
- ♪ It's not gonna happen like that. ♪
- [Both] ♪ 'Cause I ain't
no hollaback girl. ♪
♪ No, I ain't no hollaback girl. ♪
(ding)
- I actually did need a break.
- How y'all doing?
- Ah, nope.
(laughs)
- Think I want the barbecue.
- Ah Nope.
Where are you from? The bayou?
- I do have a Cleavage heart.
- You have a pretty nice, I'm just saying.
- You take the bra off, Imma trip.
(laughter)
So, you put on two bras.
A smaller one and your regular bra.
And boom.
Now, you're gonna pass out in hour three.
(laughter)
- So my kids literally ask for my music
all the time in the car
and I'm like, "Look, the window's down."
I'm not about to pull up at a red light.
(laughter and applause)
She's a makeup artist turned
True Crime phenomenon.
- They're just like the normal
people who live next door.
- Well that is terrifying news.
(laughter)
- If you replace COVID with the word "you"
in every line of "Because
of You" by Kelly Clarkson,
every lyric applies.
- Because of COVID.
You're like a,
You're a huge star.
I don't know,
News flash.
- [Ariana Grande] What
are you talking about,
Kelly Clarkson?
- [Kelly Clarkson] What?
- I just finished wrapping up
the sequel to Enchanted and,
(screams and applause)
- I need to go to the bathroom.
(laughter)
- When a college student and single mother
couldn't find a babysitter,
she emailed her professor
explaining she'd have to miss class.
Instead, check it out.
He offered to babysit
her son during class.
It's incredible and also very brave.
- If hadn't gotten divorced,
I never would've met Joe.
I wouldn't have the
beautiful family I have now.
Over time, you heal.
You're gonna be surprised,
and I can't wait until
that day comes for you.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Well,
John Cena is in Fast Nine.
So how did he end up in the movie?
- You could have cast
anybody to be my brother.
Anybody.
But I had this strange feeling
that Paul Walker accepted.
- Oh. That's magical
- She thinks she's talking
to a producer on the show.
However,
it's just me.
- Okay.
(dramatic music)
- Hi.
(dramatic sound)
Could you guys bring in
the birthday present?
It's my signature guitar.
So you can hang it up
or you can learn to play it
or whatever you want.
- When they noticed a homeless man
outside of their building,
they didn't ignore him.
They befriended him.
- So we said, "What can we do for you"
"that truly would help you?"
And he's like, "All I really would want"
"was to be reconnected with my family"
"'cause I haven't seen them in 20 years."
I posted an update
and said we found his family.
You could see in that moment
that even though 20 years had passed,
like, that was it.
That was love.
(applause)
- Wow.
You're like a different dude with a child.
- After I lost my parents,
I genuinely felt, Kelly,
I would never feel that kind of love
until I saw the scan of
him for the first time.
- Yeah.
- And from that moment I saw the scan,
it was like that was it.
- Please welcome Hannah Waddingham, y'all.
(applause and upbeat music)
We just shut the door
on Hannah Waddingham.
(laughter)
- When I first moved out here,
I moved with two of my girlfriends
'cause we were like,
"We don't have any responsibilities."
"We should try L.A."
And Chris Kattan, they had become friends,
and he was like, "You can
stay in my pool house."
And the other two of us
didn't have anywhere to stay.
So we just, like, secretly
would go in and out
the back of this pool house.
That was like our housing
for the first three months.
- I knew it this whole time.
(laughter and applause)
- Have you seen an alien?
Have you ever had an experience?
- Yes.
So I woke up in my room
and there was like three beings.
- No!
- And they were like, "Do
you want to see your planet?"
- Hell yeah.
- I was like, "Hell yeah. Let's go."
(cheering)
- What's up, Kim? What's up?
Give it up for 'N Sync.
So y'all brought Salt-N-Pepper
and En Vogue with you today
because you have a big
announcement, right?
- We do, and we are
announcing our mix tape tour.
(cheers)
- Like, I think there's a balance between
me and somebody who's eating
fast food all the time.
I think, like, I need,
- So me.
I'm just kidding.
I don't eat fast food all the time.
- I mean, me going off my path
might be like having a banana, but,
- No.
(laughter)
Visually, I always love your lyrics, too
'cause it's like paint.
You paint such a great visual for me,
and I love that.
- I don't want to burst your bubble.
- Okay. I'm gonna drink my tea.
You're like, "So, this was about,"
- At the time, I wanted to become a pilot.
I was like I wanted to learn to fly.
- Oh my god.
- Like, I did.
(applause)
- Would you rather be
friends with Schmidt or Nick?
- I think I sound a lot like Schmidt
and look a lot like Schmidt,
and it would be too much of that.
- When my son was two years old,
he started to name new
toys with the name Joe.
Shortly after,
we found out that an old
man died in our house
and yes, his name was Joe.
(upbeat music)
We use apps. Are you in,
- Oh, I'm on so many apps
and I gotta say,
dating's bad.
(laughter)
- I like Juanita so much.
Her story is so cool.
So I want to actually surprise her
and actually just call her.
Hi. How are you?
(laughs)
I didn't just win one Sports Emmy.
I won those Sports Emmy's.
(cheering and dramatic music)
Yeah!
We're the tailgate.
The tailgate, people.
Yeah.
I'm doing great. What!
- You're a chip licker?
- I'm a chip licker.
(shouts and cheers)
It was like happiness. A little party.
(upbeat music)
- ♪ Since you been gone ♪
- I've got some tea for you.
- I'm very excited.
(cheers)
- I'm going to share the story
behind our song "Wrecked."
(applause)
- Wiki wiki wiki.
- That's for Christmas?
- It's gonna be horrible.
Wayfair.
You've got just what I need.
- [Kelly Clarkson]
You're just what I need.
(ding)
- They do.
(laughter)
(ding)
(upbeat music)